Ronnie and Stephanie of course are
getting married in October we do have
clips of them with that Elvis
impersonator who's going to officiate
their wedding because Ronnie
Ronnie remember the conversation yeah I
have clips of it it's crazy the guy's
standing there full on Elvis Alden and
then the guy has a guitar and he even
gives himself Rim shots like whenever he
says something he thinks is funny he
hits the guitar so question I'm down at
the altar I don't walk down the aisle
usually you're already waiting correct
yeah and then the best man maid of honor
comes down I'll sing as they come down
yeah right we'll pick out a song for
that okay and then she comes down
because we're having a very strong oh
that's cool who's giving you away my dad
yeah so I'll sing he'll come down then
I'll stop singing and I'll and he stands
there and just says uh I'll say who
gives this Pride away and then he'll say
I do and shake his hands
to act professionally and I'd say give
away the bride
uh she feels it's like presenting her as
a gift to Ronnie giving her away
I'll see who presents this bride he'll
give you a kiss Shake run his hand no
punching no swinging you know keep it
clean it's not Mr and Mrs
yeah of course you want it first
Stephanie and Ronnie okay
I'll put a note guys laughing it is
well her point is not Mr and Mrs Ronnie
Mund it's Mr and Mrs Ronnie and
Stephanie Mund but he's sort of like you
you got Elvis marrying you you
've been married
I keep cutting it off whatever you want
see how every time he says something he
hits the guitar it's like he's got Rim
shots yeah but you know I don't even
know that this Elvis dude is writing
down what Stephanie's saying I don't
think he's gonna remember when the
wedding is happening he's not gonna
remember this yeah I mean he's
concentrating on being Elvis see why I
didn't want her Sarah Marshall
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's kind of a very traditional meeting
Stephanie's talking about her concerns
and Ronnie's like oh here we go I know
this is like Archie Bunker and she's
like his daughter yeah
you know honestly Elvis was with a 14
year old he might not be the most
feminist choice to handle a wedding you
know what I mean
was laughing at everything yeah he's not
taking it all that no one's taking it
all that seriously I tend to do a short
ceremony I mean you want it longer I
like it short sure it's good but we are
going to do our own though you'll have
them written or on a phone or something
like that and I bought little books
if you go there you have anything
written out that will be upset at you
I'll write it down and you can print it
out on the prompter I can't I can't see
your vowels before you get them you
don't have to read it you just stick it
in the thing and print it this is going
to be fun after you do the Rings is
there any pegging or anything like this
just check him out later on
nothing like a serious wedding Ron how
many people you got coming for the whole
wedding 172.
so let's cut the [__] I'm going to
say it for Ronnie I'm going to do them
I'm gonna give him the best wedding gift
he ever got which is to say to everybody
[__] these gifts just give them cash you
can't say it toaster yeah he knows he's
not looking for your toaster oh stop it
what's Fred giving that's what I want to
know I'm going to match Fred what did
you get you're going to be off the hook
pretty easily I get what did you guys
but I did not give him 5 000. oh you
gave him 500 correct
and I think that's appropriate what
house did you go to it didn't come it
was a blank dude it was a blank check
with no signature
that can't be
what do you mean it can't be
okay I can't believe that I did that but
uh dude
are you serious yeah I'm serious dude
you better go back and check your
checkbook because like I have one you
don't have a checklist I have a
checkbook but I don't keep records of
that [__] I write so infrequently I
write a check
take a picture of that and send it to me
no I thought it was a joke I threw it in
the garbage oh okay
I thought it was a joke and we just said
oh okay that was nice of prayer that's
okay I don't care doesn't this back up
my whole stance on Fred that he's like
the strangest guy on the planet
well that's your business that's your
opinion no you just you're just gonna I
don't know if I even did that when it
came we thought it was a joke we thought
it was like some old checking account
that you probably had that that's closed
out I'm serious well it's closed out if
it was and and we thought it was like
you know that's Fred he's funny he was
black and I was not trying to be funny
and uh I apologize if that's true if
that's indeed true dude it's true
Stephanie in here I'll get her yeah get
Stephanie in here
I'll ask her Stephanie hey what's
happening hi Steph you look great
don't mind me I was just about you look
terrific by the way no you look
fantastic it's good to see you in the
big ball could you describe for us what
you received from Fred as a wedding gift
[Laughter]
a blank check
with no signature wow wow
wow we thought we thought it was a joke
Fred swears he sent you 500 I'm texting
my wife now I gotta now now this is
driving me nuts I'm good
all right Stephanie Stephanie that's
Ronnie's bride to be I have Fred you
sent them a blank check here I've gotten
to the bottom of this I believe you
Ronnie because here's the deal that's
why I couldn't believe it
Allison was supposed to write that check
yeah and it wasn't me
I mean I'm not throwing a run to the bus
I asked her is it okay there you are no
I'm not I asked her is it okay because I
went did I not write a check and she
goes I I thought she goes I thought I
wrote it
so our good thing we brought it up my
apologies if you want venmo I'll venmo
with you or else whatever you're having
I'm glad I ripped it up though I really
apologize no I think you know Fred I you
know I thought it was maybe like a [__]
when it comes to that I wouldn't [__]
with you on there no Fred ain't right in
any beds for the show he's not on that
no he's too busy
yeah he's retired he doesn't care you
know when it comes to me I figured maybe
the puppet sent it you know what I'm
saying there you go bro
foreign